bonsoir yves lefebvre merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france le dépôt
des menottes à 18h01 devant les
commissariats de police c'est un message
fort est ce qu'on n'oserait dire ce soir
une mise en garde adressée acquis à
votre ministre bien évidemment adressé à
nos deux ministres ses propos de lundi
soir dans son point presse dans sa
conférence de presse sans inacceptables
notamment et voulait fort bien relaté en
présentation notamment à travers la
suppression selon ses dires du la
technique du contrôle de tête
communément appelées oat les
d'étranglement mais c'est un contrôle de
tête c'est comme ça a été mes collègues
ont été déformés c'est comme ça que j'ai
été formé et c'est comme ça mes
collègues sens contraint aujourd'hui
d'intervenir et exclusivement pour
interpeller neutraliser des personnes
qui ne veulent pas se soumettre à un
contrôle et qui ne veulent pas se
soumettre à l'interpellation d'un
christophe castaner se doit
impérativement sauf de encore plus je
dirais embrasé la police nationale de
revenir sur cette position est de nous
réaffirmer dans les toutes prochaines
heures que la clé d'étranglement le je
dirais la la la la la matière la manière
de contrôler le contrôle de tête des
personnes interpellées sera mise en
place maintenus et qu'un groupe de
travail devra être initié sans des
lettres pour éventuellement déterminer
une nouvelle technique qui soit aussi
efficace et permettant à mes collègues
d'intervenir en toute sécurité faute de
quoi la gestion je dirais les gestes des
actes symboliques de ce soir partout en
france avec parfois je dirais beaucoup
plus que je tombe n'espérait avoir deux
collègues
je pense notamment à toulouse où plus de
300 policiers ont déposé les menottes ce
soir c'est un risque de durer et moi je
le ferai durée c'est une certitude il le
faire on sent une colère quel est votre
état d'esprit l'état d'esprit des
troupes ce soir clairement vous vous
sentez trail lâché par là les
hiérarchies
papa la hiérarchie par le ministre
trahie lâché par ses ministres le
président de la république
oui bien sûr mais par le ministre bien
évidemment mais il l'a reconnu lui-même
il a reconnu avoir commis énormément
d'erreurs lors de cette conférence de
presse alors effectivement thaler votre
reporter parlait de cela je me permets
de me re cité on l'envoyait dans les
corps de ces après midi on était très
clair nous on veut que le contrôle de
tête soit autorisée on veut bien
évidemment on veut bien accepter je
dirais le tester pour une période de
trois mois le nouveau pistolet à
impulsion électrique le fameux dit azer
mais certainement pas de le généraliser
pour remplacer les méthodes à peu
habituels est connu de tous est
maîtrisée de tous de contrôle de tête
voilà c'est voyez ces deux points
essentiels et bien évidemment la
supposée éventuels soupçons de
probabilité voilà j'en passe et des
meilleurs non il ya présomption
d'innocence mais si les faits de racisme
sont avérés il y aura bien évidemment
mais uniquement s'ils sont avérés il y
aura suspension elle s'imposera et nous
la soutiendrons la matière vous vous
l'évoquez vous avez donc été reçus par
christophe castaner il ya eu une forme
effectivement de mea culpa dans quel
état d'esprit vous sentez le ministre
aujourd'hui
on a tenté un ménisque particulièrement
je dirais
touché par la crise touché par là
aujourd'hui
l'énoncé les policiers le le slogan des
policiers on ne l'a plus confiance dans
notre ministre depuis ce 2 puisqu'il a
dit lundi après midi
voilà moi j'ai faim une image chez un
peu employé de métaphores tout à l'heure
si vous reconquérir la confiance et
policiers valeo plie mais il est au pied
de l'himalaya il a tout l'himalaya à
grimper et sans bouteille d'oxygène donc
il n'est pas arrivé au bout il a du
boulot il va falloir qu'ils oeuvrent
pour ça pour redonner la confiance est
expirée espérer ce qui n'est pas acquis
d'avancé
reconquérir la confiance des policiers
républicains edouard philippe lui a
certainement tenter d'adoucir un petit
peu les choses en tout cas d'arrondir
les angles je ne veux pas que la peur
change de camp que la présomption passe
de celui qui troublent l'ordre public à
celui qui le défend si nous acceptons
cette facilité de l'esprit sous le coup
d'une émotion légitime et partager la
république bascule est ce que c'est de
nature tout de même à vous rassurer
non vous savez le discours politique il
ya bien longtemps que je n'y crois plus
et qui plus est depuis je suis dans mes
fonctions de son intérêt général du
syndicat majoritaire la police nationale
au delà des mots de christophe castaner
au delà des mots d'edouard philippe au
delà peut-être des mots en cette fin de
semaine des manuels macro nous on veut
simplement des gestes et le geste je me
répète c'est la remise en activité du
contrôle de tête et la présomption
d'innocence pour les policiers et les
expérimentations du taser nouvelle
génération sur une période donnée
et là effectivement ça sera un début de
commencement le tirage de reconquête de
crédibilité du musée intérieure et du
gouvernement pour les policiers on a
parlé yves lefebvre de ce sondage 69%
des français qui ne font pas confiance
en la police on imagine que ça vous fait
pas plaisir vous vous l'expliquez
comment cette rupture il ya selon vous
tout simplement une forme d'injustice de
manipulation peut-être voilà dans un
contexte tendu par la sphère flins et
aux états unis où il ya vraiment une
forme de divorce avec peut-être des
erreurs de la part de vos collègues
parfois comment en tout cas vous vous
l'expliquer
vous savez moi j'ai lu un sondage d lab
effectivement depuis ce matin je crois
même d'hier on parle de 69% des français
qui se satisfont de la police nationale
qui ont confiance dans la police
nationale
donc il finit le 31 % aujourd'hui c'est
aussi savez c'est une déliquescence du
pouvoir public
c'est une déliquescence au jo du fait
que ce soir je suis en direct de bobigny
du fait que l'on ait supprimé tous les
services publics dans certains quartiers
dans des zones de non droit il ya
effectivement une opération de
reconquête à avoir mais cette opération
de reconquête un repose sur les épaules
frêles près les épaules des politiques
aujourd'hui et ce certainement pas au
policier aurait pu bien de devoir
supporter ce désamour aujourd'hui
qu'elle est clairement le message que
vous adressez à jean christophe castaner
on parle beaucoup des manifestations qui
pourront peut-être avoir lieu à la
rentrée
ce serait évidemment compliqué on
imagine pour le ministre de l'intérieur
de ne pas pouvoir compter sur sa police
à ce moment là vous savez pendant les
épisodes de gilets jaunes de novembre a
quasiment au mois de mai de novembre
2010 8 ohms admettre 2019 la république
a tenu grâce à ti aux policiers et aux
gendarmes
donc effectivement si christophe
castaner n'arrive pas à monter juste en
audi malaya avant les mouvements sociaux
du mois de septembre il aura du mal à
pouvoir compter sur sa police parce que
nous aujourd'hui on concert ne plus
pouvoir compter sur une liste c'est à
lui il allait il a la balle et balmont
il a les cartes en main aujourd'hui la
balle est dans son camp
c'est à lui d'agir on nous répondons
favorablement à nos trois revendications
que je vous ai annoncé tout à l'heure
merci yves lefebvre tient à faire une
petite rectification le concernant
effectivement 1 69% des français font
confiance à leur police merci et vous il
veut le faire en tout cas d'avoir été en
direct avec mon sur rt france